I don't like to brag but being here five
years in a row I feel like I'm really
becoming a comic-con expert you know
Rhea really though yeah no no I know
don't be a dick about it yeah I really
I'm gonna say this I'm gonna say when it
comes to comic books superhero movies
sci-fi fantasy all things comic-con I
think there is literally literally no
bigger expert than Conan O'Brien right
here I really believe that okay fine
I mean you should have no problem then
passing the just invented Comic Con
citizenship test administered by a true
Comic Con legend he's one of the stars
the upcoming Netflix series Dark Crystal
age of resistant and oh yeah he's Luke
Epping Skywalker it's work
[Music]
okay all right Wow the pressures home I
got a job but we just we just want you
know we we we just lost the Veronica
Mars cast that's on you man I'm that was
beautiful that was fantastic overwhelm
me but yeah thanks thanks for having me
Conan it to a certain extent Andy I mean
I didn't stand in the way but it was it
is an amazing place to be incredible and
listen I've been coming here I remember
I was here years before I met George
Lucas and it was the year they said you
know there's gonna be they said there's
gonna be 5,000 people here this year
right right and that was a big deal over
the big deal wouldn't we all set and how
many will be women yeah well it's an
honor that you would they come here to
administer this very serious test what
you were saying I have to tell you I
think you might not know everything
about comic-con I hate to differ with
you here you're clearly a very powerful
figure here but I know everything about
comic ah
[Music]
you have much to learn my young battle
[Applause]
alright well let's let's do this alright
ask me anything
alright here we go every first question
in the Marvel movies what planet is that
eyes from Titan in what issue of what
comic book did Batman make his first
appearance Detective Comics number 27
what is Kepler what is Captain America's
real name
Mike United States what do you call a
starship that has to move back in with
his the starship that has to move back
in with his parents because of a
crushing student debt the millennial
Falcon how can you tell Batman is 80 his
utility belt comes up to his nipples
an ambitious young scientist and a bunch
of top-notch volunteer scientists land
on a planet inhabited by a race of
peace-loving vegetarians which 1918
Danish film directed by Holger Madsen am
I talking about who gives a [ __ ] how do
we know that the plan of the Aged takes
place on earth they're wearing Magga
hats
okay now I'm gonna name an x-man and you
tell me what their superpower okay
storm weather control Nightcrawler
teleportation Wolverine singing and
dancing at the Toni's okay now what
sci-fi movie from 1988 really resonates
with Eric and Donald Trump jr. my
stepmother is an alien hmm
all right come on let's get serious
what Star Wars character scares men the
most are to me too
how many new avatar movies are being
produced for too many what is the real
identity of Iron Man Tony Stark
Black Widow Natasha Romanov the ancient
one Bernie Sanders
now if Superman arrived today the
president would tell him to go back
where he came from
what do people would do most people who
did it Mos Eisley get space herpes and
what is the number one sexually
transmitted disease among wizardry
students Hogwarts what's the one day a
year I rarely leave the house may the
fourth and why is that because of your
annual May the third mark hamill
margarita marathon okay
how will the walking dead end the
zombies learn how to ride a scooters
even after all these years what do I
still enjoy saying to bodybuilders these
aren't the droids I'm looking for
[Applause]
I'm sorry it's such an iconic line I
couldn't say the joke version in front
of you
I was a much better at rehearsal yeah
yeah I know what did my travel agents
say when I went to Norway Luke use the
fjords what's the one thing
I keep checking disease my fly's open
alright what's the one thing Ariston
Ford taught me that I'll never forget
how to make a bong from a lightsaber
finally I'm going to give you a title of
a Star Wars film and I want you to name
the corresponding porn parody title
ready for this one yeah
the Empire Strikes Back the Empire
strokes butts Attack of the Clones a
slap of the bones revenge of the sith
revenge of the stiff a new hope a new
grope The Phantom Menace the fan of man
ass rogue one robe 69 and finally the
rise of Skywalker the rise of Skywalker
[Applause]